you're able to see your son
um you're are are you getting divorced
you're like we're just it's just
the issue was I was like Nikki when I
get out of Florida I will move anywhere
with you except LA because
SoCal is where Sheckler's meetings are
it's where I hike with the shaman do
ceremonies and all my silver skater
friends are there if I'm in La it could
trigger a relapse so I'm not moving
there with you I'll move to any city
except there and then I'm like oh so you
finally got a place what town she's like
Burbank I ain't Nikki that's Los Angeles
I'm like I'm not moving there with you
I'm so we're just like
I don't know what you want to call it
but it was weird on TMZ they said that
uh that that Nikki filed something with
the custody related yeah but not
divorced right like she wants to be
married yeah but she wants like a
custody of of your son yeah well the
thing that I'll always hear about and
she'll never uh let it go is that when
we got into this uh argument which was
basically about nothing she has this
thing where she answers questions with
questions and she talks in circles and
she beats around the bush so this went
on for three hours Nikki it would mean a
lot to Danny way if you come to his
going away party because he's moving to
Hawaii for good well I'd love to go all
right cool let's go well I'm not gonna
let Phoenix sleep on some cold wooden
ass floor all right well then don't go
well I'd love to go all right cool let's
go well I'm not gonna let Phoenix leave
on some cold one therefore then don't go
well I'd love to go well then let's go
we did this [ __ ] for three hours till I
punched out a mirror in front of Phoenix
at the age of three and a half or some
[ __ ] and so stormed off and went to the
party without her so because of that
that's when she was like I'm falling for
custody and blah blah blah blah I think
that if we were to be like
Fair
there's been enough like kind of like
alarming stuff that that's shown up on
Instagram TMZ and stuff that there
there's I think a pretty valid argument
for being concerned about what happens
around Phoenix yeah
um and uh I mean dude and and I I feel
for you so much man like I want so much
for you to just get get good right and
let there be no and when I was
constantly living with him and her I
took advantage of that you know like I I
would wanna go out elsewhere and hang
out with friends and whatever but now
that I'm not living with them all I want
to do is play with them watch cartoons
with them and you know spend quality
time with them and she always rubs it in
my face like well you didn't want to do
that when you had the ability to do I'm
like yeah but I had to do a year and a
half of not seeing it I'm in Florida and
and I realized that he is everything to
me and that's all I want to do like
it's like would you realize that how
much time do you want me to do if I did
10 years of treatment that's still not
good enough to you apparently
like
I mean there's there's really two two
sides of it yeah and uh you know because
I follow caption cream stain
I'm able to see more of you with Phoenix
you know I'm able to see more of you
with Phoenix and and it warms my heart
you know like I think you should be with
Phoenix like uh I love that you care
about being with them I love how much
you love him yeah I also see from the
other side that if I'm Nikki and there's
like any one of these crazy meltdowns
which uh you know arguably could happen
you know if there's some crazy meltdown
like like a rerun of uh of situations
that we've seen even in the past then if
I'm Nikki that happens I'm worried about
child protective services coming and
taking being away from me because
Phoenix was exposed to that so what what
that tells me is that we just need we
need to give get you a track record
right for being a responsible like
healthy clean and sober guy yeah and and
not that it's like something that has to
be done but when I do see them I always
bring somebody like the shaman or
Picasso or Beaver Fleming or somebody
that Nikki trusts that is around me to
if anything did happen they would be
able to you know there's this thing that
only Danny Way and the shaman can do is
they say the word oga Boga and I just
shut my mouth behave and do exactly what
they say and I can only speak if spoken
too
yes sir
that's uh that's a start
do you like shopping on Amazon I I do
and good news is Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude